thousands of Starbucks stores will shut
down this afternoon so employees can get
racial bias training you may recall the
Starbucks faced controversy after a
manager called police on two black men
who were arrested after asking to use
the bathroom without buying anything
drinka Duncan is out of Starbucks in
Fair Lawn New Jersey that's just west of
New York City Jericho good morning good
morning this Starbucks behind me is open
right now but it will close at 2:30 and
normally it's open until 11 p.m. now
Starbucks says that closing these stores
is just the first step it is not
necessarily the solution they have
teamed up with several civil rights
organizations including the
n-double-a-cp to help them create
today's curriculum Starbucks says the
program will set the foundation for a
longer term anti-bias diversity equity
and inclusion effort employees will
reportedly watch videos one featuring
rapper common and they'll participate in
discussions the training is part of
Starbucks initiative to improve the
coffee giant's diversity education after
last month's incident in Philadelphia
which Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
called reprehensible the company will
close more than 8,000 stores this
afternoon the closures are estimated to
cost Starbucks
about 12 million dollars now around
7,000 licensed stores in hotels airports
and colleges they will remain open but
managers will receive research materials
and training material that they will
then give to those employees at another
time Gail
alright tarika thank you